Mortal Kombat the memories okay so I am
literally the biggest Mortal Kombat fan
that I actually know me with Mortal
Kombat 2 back in the day that [ __ ] was
dangerous and they've been talking about
a Mortal Kombat reboot movie for about
10 years now but it's never actually
gone anywhere until maybe now so
yesterday on slash film they posted this
Mortal Kombat video but no one really
knew what it was they didn't know if it
was promoting a new game a new movie
what and it turns out it's a pitch video
a video that you make when you show us
to do what you want to make which is
kind of circular example you tell Warner
Brothers I want to make a Mortal Kombat
movie when they say you make this video
and show it to him so they kind of know
what you have in mind when you say I
want to direct a Mortal Kombat movie
which was exactly what Zack Snyder had
to do when he was pitching 302 Warner
Brothers apparently it's a Warner
Brothers thing now when watching this
video I think Mortal Kombat fans are
gonna be like oh [ __ ] dude that is
awesome and Mortal Kombat fans are gonna
be like that is not Mortal Kombat yeah
fans will say both however people who
are oblivious to Mortal Kombat Laura
they'll probably be like that looks
interesting so when watching this video
you will see that they've done away with
the whole multi-dimensional thing and
they put Mortal Kombat in the world of
realistic they have Nolan Eyes mortal
kombat so to speak pretty much the way
people describe these things and I've
heard a couple people say that they're
afraid that it's gonna be just so
different and the answer is yeah yes it
will anything that's different than the
last shitty Mortal Kombat movie is okay
it is okay to be different than
something that is [ __ ] horrible again
Mortal Kombat fan I mean one of the
characters that it shows is a cannibal
with a skin disorder a skin disorder
that actually does exist I googled it
after watching this I mean they went
that route instead of making him a you
know reptile man that's cool and I'm not
saying they do show Barack I'm just
saying if they did show Baraka he
probably does look better than Ryan
Reynolds did as Baraka and Wolverine
wait he wasn't Barack and Wolverine so
it looks like they're going straight for
a hard R gritty realistic Mortal Kombat
reboot and I say bring that [ __ ] on I
mean honestly everyone can agree that
Mortal Kombat's needed something to hit
it in the face for years now a DC thing
doing do I do it for me I mean pretty
safe to say Mortal Kombat's got one more
movie in it this is their one shot might
as well make it a realistic ray
envisioning but if this movie they want
to do is anything like this video I am
pumped so bring on the realistic combat
so if you're a Mortal Kombat fan or
you're not a Mortal Kombat fan doesn't
matter check out the video I think it's
really cool I put the link below it's
about 7 minutes long it's cool and if
you remember my submission video for the
Olympus PEN your story challenge the
voting is going on until the 18th if you
haven't voted yet just go there that
video is a video response to this video
is right below click on that and
remember to vote thumbs up your guys's
support has been and continues to be
really appreciated so thank you so the
big question is the new take on the
Mortal Kombat franchise I imagine the
studio's going on you the people's
reaction so this is your time what do
you think comment below let them know
[Music]